things are going green at gate a 15 it's
the site of frankfurt's first Green Gate
where the public can see firsthand how
Frankfurt Airport is trying to reduce
its reliance on fossil fuels it's all
part of the e port on project a research
project designed to help the airport and
industry partners increase the number of
electric vehicles in the airline
industry up to 20 different vehicles are
used to load and maintain a modern
commercial flight and all those motors
are a major source of co2 but it doesn't
have to be that way say airport
officials around fifteen percent of our
carbon emissions at the airport are from
vehicles on the tarmac we want to cut
down on that from the three thousand
vehicles in our fleet around ten percent
are electric we're hoping to increase
that number dramatically it's still
early days for frankfurt's e-mobility
switch but airport representatives
believe it brings frankfurt one step
closer to its goal of maintaining a
fleet of one hundred percent electric
vehicles